l'image que donne l'angleterre depuis
hier vient percuter ce que nous sommes
ou plutôt ce que nous ne sommes plus le
royaume est capable l'espace de quelques
jours d'oublier ces différences
d'effacer ces querelles d'enterrer ses
misères pour ensemble célébrer la reine
pour ensemble sanctifier le pays pour
ensemble glorifier son histoire la reine
a fait une apparition au balcon de
buckingham cet après midi elle qui
s'était fait particulièrement discrète
lors de ces quatre jours de jubiler et
en cette dernière journée de festivités
le drapeau a été hissé au dessus du
palais preuve de la présence d'elisabeth
2 en fin d'après midi alors que la foule
avait envahi the mall l'avenue qui mène
à buckingham la fameuse poupée barbie de
la haine j'avais vu à l'hélice comme une
peau de fesses de bébé à
l'extraordinaire respecter ça marche et
ça m'a
dit pas je voulais dire qu'elle à la
police
oui je pouvais avoir les larmes aux yeux
hier en voyant ce grand peuple donné au
monde entier une vitrine de féliciter en
pensant aussi qu'à paris ou à marseille
aucun rassemblement de cette ampleur des
millions d'anglais dans la rue serait
possible sans qu'une grève de métro
pertur de la fête sans que des blacks
blocs cassent des vitrines sans que des
voyous surgissent de jeunes 16 ou
l'angleterre et ce que nous ne sommes
plus multiples mais unis de toute façon
on ne peut pas comparer la france et la
grande bretagne
secib et n'diaye vous souvenez de sid et
n'diaye l'ancien porte parole du
gouvernement qu'il disait mais non peut
pas comparer les deux pays parce que
notre elisabeth is born alors que leur
elizabeth on va la voir la nôtre
elisabeth pied on la voit pas voilà
voilà notre elisabeth is born top alors
que leur réserve elisabeth a bientôt
dead depuis combien de temps vous vivez
en espagne depuis 1994 qu'est ce qui
vous a plu pourquoi vous êtes allez on
est sympa
au départ je suis allée pondérée des
raisons professionnelles
et fiscales
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord coupole mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que il faut aussi que
les gens travaillent aujourd'hui on a
l'impression alors les gens mais en
france on travaille pas suffisamment
quand par ailleurs on veut pas commencer
tôt oui on peut perdre mais c'est vrai
il faut le reconnaître comparé aux
autres pays je dis pas tout le monde
d'aujourd'hui en effet les volières
avaié autrement ils peuvent plus
accepter
climatique tu as terminé ses études en
génie climatique il ya donc un mec
intelligent dans tout public et il est à
côté de tourner et j'ai senti ça elle
sentit le génie climatique en mai
attention climatique où tu travailles
dans la clim ouais tout ce qui est
système énergétique et
pour les autres je vais te voilà le
troisième la dernière non cartman ces
morts mais y'a rien n'y a pas de
rattrapage non mais à lens attend j'ai
[Rires]
passé revient pas sentiers
qu'est ce que tu veux exactement
écoutez michel sardou quelques secondes
on l'écoutera peut-être un autre moment
michel sardou s'est confié dans les
colonnes de paris match j'ai regardé
voilà ce qu'il dit mélenchon est
toujours dans les excès maintenant il se
déclare premier ministre attention
danger s'il passe je veux dire ça a le
mérite d'être claire et jean luc
mélenchon lui a répondu monsieur michel
sardou m'accorder vous un entretien
m'accorderez vous un entretien je veux
vous convaincre de rester en france
quand nous aurons gagné beaucoup de
français vous aime et le pays a besoin
de votre affection aussi vous regardez
ses news non mais là non en fait je vais
être tout à fait honnête avec vous je
regarde mais quand je dis très peu c'est
même quasiment jamais les télés d'un
fois en continu aucune manon aucune
aucune mais vraiment même pas france en
faut donc je suis honnête avec vous
ah qu'est ce qui se passe une
manifestante qui vient sa tâche et là au
filet au pied du poteau
la jeune femme vous allez le voir
voulait agir contre l'inaction
climatique du gouvernement c'est ce
qu'elle pense elle a été évacué en
douceur par la sécurité mais hué
copieusement par le public du court
central la télé d'infos en continu non
je regarde jamais parce que ça mousse où
j'ai pas le temps et ça me saoule oui ça
me saoule il ya un côté
ou vous maintient comme ça en haleine et
puis si vous voulez pour moi un journal
c'est pas quelqu'un qui a un micro comme
ça et qui parle d' avoir une caméra
c'est quelqu'un qui va sur le terrain
qui va rencontrer des gens qui va
prendre des risques comme on l'a dit en
ukraine qui va prendre des espaces qu'il
fait une enquête un peu costaud voilà
merci matthieu chedid et ensuite on vous
retrouvera au zénith dans tous les
zénith de france j'adore bold est un job
de retour là bas